a tremendous thing was done over the
last number of months but really if you
go back to it over the last number of
years we had the witch hunt it started
from the day we came down the elevator
myself and our future first lady who's
with us right now
[Applause]
[Music]
and it never really stopped we've been
going through this now for over three
years it was evil it was corrupt it was
dirty cups
it was leakers and Liars and this should
never ever happen to another president
ever I don't know that other presidents
would have been able to take it some
people said no they wouldn't have but I
can tell you at a minimum you have to
focus on this because it can get away
very quickly no matter who you have with
you it could get away very quickly it
was a disgrace
had I not fired James Comey who was a
disaster by the way it's possible I
wouldn't even be standing here right now
we caught him in the act
dirty cups bad people if this happened
to President Obama a lot of people would
have been in jail for a long time
already many many years I want to start
by thanking some of and I call them
friends because you know you develop
friendships and relationships when
you're in battle and war much more so
than gee let's have a normal situation
with all that we've gone through we've
done I think more than any president and
administration and really I say for the
most part Republican Congressmen
Congress women and Republican senators
we've done more than any administration
in the first few years you look at all
of the things we've done I watched this
morning as they tried to take credit for
the stock market from
from think of that let me tell you if we
didn't win the stock market would have
crashed and the market was going up a
lot before the election because it was
looking like we had a good chance to win
and then went up tremendously from the
time we won the election till the time
we took office which was November 8th to
January 20th and that's our credit
that's all our credit and leading up to
that point was our credit because there
was hope and one of the reasons the
stock markets gone up so much in the
last few days is people think we're
doing so well they liked the State of
the Union speech
it really is it's a true honor to give
it and Mikey in the State of the Union
speech I was with some people that have
been around they've been all over the
world and one of them said highly
sophisticated person said you know no
matter where you go in the world it
doesn't make any difference there is
nothing like what I witness tonight the
beauty the majesty of the chamber the
power of the United States the power of
the people in this room really an
amazing even I don't think there is
anything like that anywhere in the world
you can go to any other country you can
go to any other location any other place
it's the beauty of everything it's what
it represents and how it represents our
country I want to start by introducing
some of the people that are here I know
some are gonna be left out but they work
so hard
and this is really not a news conference
it's not a speech it's not anything it's
just we're sort of it's a celebration
because we have something that just
worked out I mean it worked out we went
through hell unfairly did nothing wrong
did nothing wrong
I've done things wrong in my life I will
admit not purposely but I've done things
wrong but this is what the end result is
we can take that home money maybe we'll
frame it it's the only good headline
I've ever had in the Washington Post
but every paper is the same does anybody
have those papers does anybody have them
because they're really like that so I
appreciate that